Riley in Northumberland election nights
first shock result when this seat turned
blue that die was cast
Boris Johnson wasn't just going to take
Labour's red wall he was going to wipe
it out for seven decades Blythe Valley
has returned and Labour MP to
Westminster but no more this old mine in
seat is Boris Johnson's territory now
and that land grab stretches from coast
to coast from Blythe to Blackpool south
to Barry to Bishop Auckland to Bolsover
and that's just the bees dozens of
labour seats turn Tory Britain's
political Mac has literally been redrawn
and the big question is can labour win
their Heartland back so Pete's basically
I just need it it's less emotional like
literally just on my eyebrows on yeah
like literally yeah you know there's one
thing business owner Peter wanted from
this election brexit their time she
thought it might never happen oh yeah
crazy three off years down the lane I'm
thinking why ever referendum if another
no wouldn't do it when when when they
called the election were you annoyed or
were you glad because she thought it's
gonna get sorted out now well yeah I
thought I wondered it just all the whole
thing needed saw note yeah that's
perfect
I'm reborn there was only one man Peter
trusted to get brexit over the line and
did you vote conservative yes I did hi
his first day I've done it and thought I
was just fed up and sick of the way
politics was good and I thought what if
anybody's gonna get work out cause
Johnson will get world how important to
you was the fact that Jeremy Corbyn led
the Labour Party was that a problem for
you when you were thinking about how to
vote well yeah
I didn't like him and I just saw you
couldn't see mr. Prime Minister on no
legacy if I wouldn't have run the bus
never mind the country there's big
business here too
105 tons yep Brendan founded a
manufacturing company here in Blythe he
thinks the region has more to offer
so you quite liked Boris Johnson's
message about unleashing Britain's
potential you thought that that was
maybe the right way to go we had a vote
on brexit it is what it is we need to
move on and I think the key importance
for us as a company and for a region is
I think just about ambition and we have
a huge amount we can either decide to
look back to the past or we can look
forward to the future we've got a huge
amount again a bit farther south to
County Durham the key target seat of
Bishop Auckland turn Tory to
emphatically Sam's family have been here
for over a century their cafe a fixture
of the local community he saw this
coming I was awarded lever and the
bottom line is this country waters to
leave it got to be a bumpy ride
we accept that but as the nation if
we're all pulling together but bumpy
ride can get then get easier Boris
promised to deliver brexit he promised
to deliver what the people water for
people want so that's why I supported
Morris the promise of an oven-ready
brexit irresistible for many former
labour voters but brexit just the
starter voters want more now they've got
a foothold in the northeast to make it
their own
as if they're deliver in the different
constituencies people here find in the
tribalism of our politics distasteful
will you find in all of the rowan back
in Westminster was it yes yes it really
is they were like kids really so they've
all getting together and sorting this
out were you surprised that Bishop
Auckland was one boy - let's just
remember 8,000 votes very surprised but
we used to say if you put your sheep
head and put labour and it would get in
it's always been Lib yeah as long as I
can remember what did you think of
Jeremy Corbyn don't mention his name
what did you think I don't think he was
the right one deliver do you think if
they get the right leader they could win
bishop all came back very quickly not
very quickly next door in Durham
Northwest another shot win for the
Tories beautiful the mines are long gone
people here finding new ways to make a
living
you've got Anna Maria there you've got
Anna Maria I've got to do like really
good supper but that is it Shane says
labour are detached from the realities
of rural life were you surprised that
the Conservatives won the election like
they did not really not really I mean
I've always thought that Labour all my
life but this year I didn't they were
saying they were going to promise this
that me again were going to put more
money into schools services national
health things like that and when they
were saying where it's gonna come from
that couldn't possibly couldn't possibly
give you the money that they were
promising for all these little rural
villages and I think people have just
had enough what would you like your
community in the next five years I want
them to bring rural villages and rural
areas up to speed with everybody else
make sure that they have got even just
the basics labour unconvincing the
Tories - with much to prove I think
they're gonna have to prove themselves
in the next few years to see if see if
the corner they are gonna uphold you
know the policies and what
put forward and if not then I think the
people may call back and bought a Ginley
about the new MP here knows who have to
build on his success if he wants to
repeat it you know this is never gonna
be taken for granted this is never gonna
be a safe conservative seat I'm gonna
have to fight here every time for votes
and I think that's one of the things
that's has changed here is that people
can now see an MP it's really fighting
it's it's a victory but it feels like a
fragile victory is that fair I think
it's as a prime minister said some
people lent us their votes to the
election some people took a punt this
time on the Conservatives thinking
Cinque
will you go forwards will you deliver
for us and I think they're gonna want to
see that delivery in a few years time
you can drive West right across the
Pennines and down to the sea without
passing through labour land after six
consecutive labour wins this time
Blackpool South turned blue - this man
worked on Labour's losing campaign what
was the message you were getting back
from voters I mean those two things
mainly as an issue of leadership but
also the the brexit issue really we can
get away from it really from Blythe to
Blackpool voters tan Tory because they
wanted a government of prime minister
who can deliver yes they turned to Boris
Johnson because of brexit but they also
turned away from Jeremy Corbyn because
of leadership he is then a prime
minister if you like on probation with
his new supporters but Boris Johnson now
has the chance to turn a toehold in
places like this in to a real foothold
if he delivers on those election
promises
and now mr. Johnson's in the driving
seat labor with a very long road back
but brexit scramble party political
identities in this election and what
harmed from red to blue could easily
turn back again mr. Johnson has a
five-year term but there is still all to
play for
and plenty to lose Beth Rigby Sky News